and minimalists hello simpletons what's
up y'all
Josh loves the patronize our our
audience we're trying to really claim in
a word Bobby so so here's the thing like
we're all foolish or gullible with
respect to something so like Ryan and I
are the head simpletons and like
everyone else
I had a at a friend today a designer
Taniya Nayak I got a a DM from her and
it's like look I made you something and
it's a link and I'm like alright she
clearly didn't make me something so
there's a spam it's somebody's hacked
her and so I text her I was like oh
you've been hacked and she's like I know
I'm so sorry she's like I clicked on it
from somebody else I can't believe it
she's like you're clearly smarter than I
am I was like I'm not smarter I'm just
way more jaded way less are way more
interesting and I'm Ryan Nicodemus and
we are the minimalist I said never going
to talk about well you've heard Bob you
already talk about interior design
well maybe talk about feng shui a little
bit we're going to talk about the
calmness of clutter free spaces and
we're gonna talk about how to have a
minimalist home that is not boring and
we're gonna do that with today's guest
Bobbie Burke is here Bobby thank you for
being so nice to have an expert on the
show to to talk about decorating because
I have no taste at all if I ever need
advice I usually text Josh and I'm like
hey what would you do if you were me I I
feel really good about that man thanks
for the affirmation probably know Bobby
from queer I he's a fellow Netflix er
and also Bobby Burke calm you can check
him out there also he has a line of
furniture at a RT we'll put a link to
that in the show notes now now Bobby
this is a listener driven show so I
thought we would get started with some
questions our first question is from
Laura in Asheville North Carolina I love
that I do forcefully that I will be
moving to any space in the near future I
think there's a good chance that I will
end up with quite a bit more square
footage than I actually need I don't
mind having some open space and I
obviously don't think that I have to
spill every corner but we're talking
about having an entire room that I
literally do not have items to put into
I will be living alone and that's
important so I'm just wondering if you
guys haven't
suggestions for what to do with a
situation like that
so Bobby it seems to me that that Laura
has a common problem a lot of Americans
have this is the average American house
is getting bigger and bigger and bigger
and because we have bigger homes I
remember I built my first home back in
my corporate days it was like this giant
McMansion monstrosity ugly disgusting
suburban home and outside of Dayton Ohio
and I I had extra space and what do I do
I felt compelled to fill the space and
that's what we do if we have 4,000
square-foot home all of a sudden we feel
like I need to fill it with with a bunch
of stuff even though I don't necessarily
need it I'm sure I'm sure that you
encounter people like this where they
have maybe some extra space and it
seemed like a good problem but we don't
necessarily have to just fill it for the
sake of filling it right correct
oddly though recently the square footage
of houses in the US have been going down
a little bit let's talk about we do a
lot of work with actual production
builders we go in and we design the
model parks and the all the decor for
the model homes and the club houses and
stuff and we're five years ago they were
building a lot of like 4,500 to 6500
square foot homes now kind of the sweet
spots like 2700 to 35 people are
realizing they don't need that much
space people are realizing they don't
need the thousand square-foot bedroom
with you know the 400 square foot closet
because they don't actually spend any
time in their bedrooms and I think
that's really being driven by
Millennials our parents kind of liked
that big house way more space than they
needed and I think this kind of older
Millennials I think probably about the
same age um we kind of felt the same way
and then we realized especially here in
the housing crisis and everything like
wait we don't need all that space yeah
so luckily I think it's been going down
a little bit but for her like that I
don't think she needs to fill the need
to fill it I think it needs to feel
comfortable I don't know it's very hard
to give two core advice without seeing a
space but when I have a big open space
like I one thing I always tell people
when they have a big space and they're
like oh I feel so uncomfortable I want
to fill it I'm like think of it as
like quiet quiet space don't feel like
you always need to fill the void of
speaking you know yeah yeah you don't
always think you know you can sit there
and enjoy silence so you don't always
need to fill the silence you don't
always also need to fill the space open
space can be beautiful if you get a few
good things that are really beautiful
people won't even notice that it's not
filled because they're focusing on the
fact that these are beautiful minimalist
pieces right so you're telling her to
come up with a meditation room that's
what it sounds like I did that remember
back in Dayton when I when I first met
my marriage in and I moved into this
condo that was too big for me Josh we
called that the tickle room we did 10
years before we dropped that bomb a
whole different color shopping I look
around not so like I had this well I had
this red chair in that room was a
meditation room but right in the center
of the room I came over one day and he
was like what is that like oh that's the
tickle room don't worry about it so so I
guess the point is if you have this
extra room so you realize if you put a
chair in there and you just sit in it
you are completely yourself Laura are
complete in an empty room and thus the
things that you fill the room with
whether it's you know a wallpaper one of
Bobby's wallpapers perhaps or some of
Bobby's furniture or you know whatever
you're filling the room with it should
aunt the experience of the room they
shouldn't just be filled for the sake of
filling it this is filled with things
that as Marie Kondo was a spark joy you
know don't just fill it with crap that's
gonna not only clutter the space but
clutter your mind totally this makes me
think of the architect we had on the
documentary Frank he talked about how
what we typically do is we will buy a
house and then we try to fit our life
and cram it into that house instead of
getting a place that actually fits our
life and that's exactly what Laura's
running up against it's like she's
trying to cram her life into this house
and yeah you don't necessarily have to
cram it full of stuff you know
we went from New York like 14 years to
LA about four years ago and oh my god
you moved to LA and did it get that you
know 4,000 square-foot house on the hill
with the pool and the longer we lived
here we live downtown first kind of a
nice transition between New York and
here I realized I didn't need that and
we ended up like just finding the
perfect house that fit our lifestyle
that the views the indoor/outdoor space
that we wanted and it's like 14 1,500
square feet and I'm like I don't need
any more I mean I could use like 50
square feet more in the bathroom I know
you think like all these years again I
had that thought process in my mind that
all that big house I need all that space
because that growing up like that's what
you're taught that's what you want but I
realized they didn't yeah I think it's
important when you when you're looking
for a new place and it sounds like Laura
is in and up into place it happens to be
too big for her and maybe this is a sort
of transition space and eventually
you'll find the space that's appropriate
for you you know I'm I'm a tiny house
advocate but not for everyone right I'm
I don't think it would work for me you
know I have a six-year-old daughter and
a wife and us living in a tiny house
they it would be you know a double
murder-suicide
I miss imagining L is the one who kills
you and yeah sure she's the murderer
[Laughter]
like I'll be walking to Runyon Canyon or
something and like I see these huge
houses up and you know Hollywood Hills
and my younger self like just dreamed of
having an amazing beautiful huge house
like that but like my adult self I still
look at it I'm like oh that would be
maybe neat to kind of own and man
imagine waking up to those views but
having that big of a house like taking
care of it that's what I don't want to
be responsible for property tags I mean
it's gonna cost 100 grand a year just to
upkeep one of those multi-million dollar
mansions it's it's kind of like a boat
like I don't want to own a boat I just
want to know someone who owns a boat
actually reminded me of one of my
favorite albums from a couple years ago
member belly's album came out and he
said I bought mutton he said I bought my
dream house but I've been having
nightmares in it yeah and there's
something about that where you you we
talked about this with the Pete Rollins
and
desire this this concept of object day
like really we think we want this thing
until we get it and then it becomes the
object of our discontent so be careful
very careful about what you want because
did someone else tell you you wanted
that a corporation or or a television
show or commercial tell you that you
want that thing or is it an actual
personal belief you have to be really
careful with difference between want and
need yeah yes and the more that you get
that you want to realize you didn't need
it yeah yes I will throw one suggestion
out for Laura if I had an extra room I
would have a peloton because that thing
is I really enjoy the peloton it it's
easy to use it's you can get on there
with live people and by the way peloton
is not sponsoring us she had too many
rooms are just too large of her she said
she's there's too much space but she has
an entire empty room yeah and in more
square footage than she needs and she's
living alone yeah yeah I'm just I mean
in all honesty just close the door yeah
right love that
just close the door like the room just
because it's there doesn't mean you need
to use it like don't waste money don't
consume more just because it's there act
like it's not close the door just in so
you don't have a heating or cooling room
yeah that's a great idea it's still live
in the home that I grew up and I just
recently got it the whole thing and
remodeled it and there's two rooms
upstairs that are completely unnecessary
like they don't need them and we
remodeled it and like change the
flooring new pond and then closed the
doors you know they're like oh what are
you gonna do with those rooms I'm like
nothing
I'm like what do you need them for my
arms like oh yeah yeah nothing I'm like
exactly just close the door right that's
all so that's the best advice just close
the door so I I have a peloton also not
a peloton ad we don't do any ads on the
podcast at all
we're like one of three podcasts in the
world that don't do ads I feel like but
I just keep ours in Ella's room and she
doesn't even really notice it's there
six yeah that's probably true but then
I'm just gonna kick her out get a job
cetera attends up on the balcony
hey Laura I'm gonna send you a copy of
our book essential there are two
chapters in there I think your only find
value in its essay collection 150 essays
about living simply but two chapters in
there one is about minimalism one is
about stuff and how we can be more
intentional with our stuff so twelve
chapters total about twelve different
areas of living intentionally but those
two in particular will will help you out
if you like our podcast you'll like the
audiobook version of essential or if you
want the book book or the e-book we're
happy to send those to you as well our
next question is from Allie in
Springville Utah we recently had a
sudden change in the course of our lives
and are now finding yourself needing to
sell a house within a short period of
time a realtor has told us that we must
stager home in order to significantly
increase the number of hired prospects
this sounds very enticing since we want
and need to sell it quickly
however instance you need to follow a
more minimalist lifestyle we have purged
many things and we want them in green
painless mentality for the rest of our
life but now with this added pressure
from the rails for prompting us to buy
certain items for the home station
process items that I don't want and I
don't need but the promise that I will
make that a will make our property more
appealing I'm finding myself feeling
sick to my stomach with the thought of
acquiring unnecessary material things
and spending money I don't have on them
what would be your suggested approach
for this kind of situation this is an
interesting problem I had a condo that I
had to kind of stage and sell and yes
there's pressure from the realtor to be
like hey if we just added these things
we could totally sell your house faster
I guess before I kind of go into what I
did like what would be your advice - I
mean I agree with the realtor you do
need to stage it you do need to take
your personality out of it you know so
many people still have so many personal
things at home that when buyers come in
they can't see themselves in your home
like your home needs to be void of
anyone that lives there it just needs to
look cool because that person needs to
imagine themselves living in it right
and if they can only see you living in
it they can't imagine themselves that
being said I can completely understand
where she's coming from and I
hate to be buying all those things so my
advice would be there's a lot of staging
companies that you can rent from um it's
often maybe a little bit more but yeah
you're not consuming you're not having
to worry about any of it afterwards and
it is definitely increasing the value of
your home or B if you do have to buy
those things buy things that are less
expensive but donate at all you know if
you're like oh I don't want to acquire
all these things well don't buy buying
you know four thousand dollars worth of
stuff to stay at your home and if you're
gonna be able to increase it by twenty
thousand dollars you're good so take
that four thousand dollars worth of
stuff and donate it to a needy family
donated to a local charity you know so
if you have to get it donate it to
somebody who actually could use it who
doesn't have enough stuff as it is and
also Ryan she mentions that she doesn't
need this stuff I would actually argue
yes you do need it if you want to sell
your home you actually need these things
in order to get a better asking price so
this isn't like maybe you don't want it
but some there are some things that I
don't want that I need right and so I
don't want the Vitamix on the counter
but apparently my husband thinks we need
it don't get me wrong I love my it
doesn't the drawer absolutely though
yeah yeah that would end my marriage no
it's exactly the advice I was thinking
it's like either rent the furniture or
yeah go and get some I actually like I
got a coffee table I went to like
Goodwill and found a decent coffee table
that was neutral it was cheap I was able
to donate it back it just cost a little
bit of money but to your point Bobby
it's like if the money you spend is
gonna be a fraction of what you're going
to gain out of it then it seems like it
might be a good investment again I can
understand not wanting to accumulate
things but I had my advice to hers don't
think of it as she's accumulating it
she's using it for a purpose and then
again if it's rented it's going back or
she can do a good thing by donating to
somebody you need and when it stops yeah
I want to stop serving a purpose like
that's when you decide to yeah how you
get rid of it the real problem here
seems to be conflicting values right
because she values minimalism and living
with less and intentionality and then
she feels that to sell this home she has
to do some things that she perceives
be as unintentional we're not deliberate
but actually I would argue it's the
opposite it is it is deliberate because
you're going to bring these things in
for a temporary period of time whether
it's renting or buying them and you're
gonna let them go in a responsible way
you're not gonna just fill a landfill
with all this sort of extra furniture so
yes yeah yeah yeah definitely you
definitely want to do that so Ali I'm
gonna recommend that we have a values
worksheet on our website if you go to
the minimalists comm /v and I would
recommend you get really clear on what
your values are and we kind of identify
these four types of values you have
these and it's kind of like a house
actually it's the foundational values of
the most important things your
relationships and your health and and
your community and and your creativity
but then we have these sort of
structural values you know you think of
like the the 2x4 is the structure of the
builds the house those are also
important not as important as a
foundation but they're pretty important
and you have some surface values what
might make things aesthetically pleasing
or add value to the home they're not as
important as your foundation but
aesthetics are still important and then
most important here to think about is
the imaginary values because they're not
real values at all they're we often say
as certain things are gonna be so
valuable to us I if I just buy that
Rolex my life will be complete
then my 15 year old self says that my 27
year old self says that I think the that
we tell ourselves these stories and
create these narratives but these are
imaginary values or what we might call
mimetic values where the the culture or
society as a whole imposes those on to
us and we buy into it but we don't have
to buy into it and so get really clear
on what your values are we'll send you a
copy of that values work for you but if
you're listen to this and you want to
download it it's free over the
minimalists comm /v ryan what time is I
know what time it is it is time for our
lightning round where we answer your
text messages text your questions and
comments to nine thirty seven two zero
two four six five four yes indeed those
texts literally go to both of our phones
I was answering a few this morning where
are you really yeah I was like I'm gonna
do five because they're like so we do
this thing called community and if you
heard of this okay
people literally send us text messages
it goes to Josh and ice phone and if we
are crazy because I open it up and it's
instant panic I'm like oh my god like
look at all these messages so this
morning I woke up I was like I'm gonna
answer five text messages and it was
really meaningful and then I was like a
plain emoji sani we couldn't open
ourselves up to that no like the very
first day our show launched it was like
6 a.m. I got up I looked at my DM I had
thousands of DM and I sat there and I
tried to respond to every single one
with ours
they're very emotional you know it's not
just about minimalist things it's you
know the stories that we've told on
queer I that you know there'd be being
gay and religion like people have been
able to connect to it and so we could
have a lot of wonderful stories but then
also a lot of heartbreaking stories yeah
and you'll go in like three messages to
eat and you're just like and the rest of
the day you're just it is yeah and we
attack sad cuz what yeah we've get it we
get a lot like one I was answering this
morning it was about someone whose mom
always buys clothes and she loves her
mom but you know she won't stop buying
clothes and what do you do and like you
can tell they're in this really tight
spot and yeah it's it is emotionally
draining because you want to put
everything you have into a documentary
about fast fashion that's what you do
yeah show them how that's a good yeah
consuming fashion is destroying our
planet and at least play on their guilt
yeah Bob you want to do you wanna start
answering our text messages if you do
text us we can't answer every question
but we do reply to quite a few of them
during the lightning round Bobby this is
where Ryan and I and now you we do our
best answer questions with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so
people can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if they like and
now you can find all of our minimal
Maxim's in one place minimal Maxim's
calm but Bobby
we really just monitor on a bit you can
ramble on and we'll we'll tweeze out
something pithy at the end of this tion
we'll make it really really nice and
post mary has a question for us what's
the best way to make a room cozy without
many accessories
warm tones mmm yeah yeah nice wood tone
I think makes things feel cozy yeah my
house is nothing but like black white
and like some wood tones yeah so it's
like I took a bluebottle coffee but like
in your house like just my outfit
outside specific concrete block and
inside is void of color except for nice
warm wood John cool yeah yeah yeah it's
funny you mentioned the emotion thing a
moment ago because I when our
documentary first came out on Netflix
2016 this it was the same thing it was
it because we tie so much emotion into
these these physical items right and and
and we tie sentimentality and in
memories of course the memories aren't
in the things the memories are on us but
these things can be triggers for some of
those memories and so the same thing
where people are like you know my
husband died 12 years ago and and I'm
still having trouble dealing with his
things and even something as as
seemingly sort of anodyne as a question
like this that mary has making a room
cozy I think what can happen our home is
you know we sort of treat it like a a
sanctuary right and we come home we do
want to have the sort of positive
emotions associated with with that space
and so you I saw video that you had and
we put a link to this in the show notes
Sean where you were doing a tour of your
home office and one thing you said like
too many colors like drive me crazy sort
of thing but for some people it might
mean that like they really want the the
purple and yellow wallpaper right some
people love that you know I just there's
so much chaos in the world that when I
get home I want no chaos you know I in
fact I rarely even put things on the
wall which was a lot of like discussion
with my wife and I mean if it wasn't for
my home needing to be in magazines
there'd be way less stuff in that room
than there already was you know a couple
years ago we did people came in to do a
home tour of my loft downtown and I
lived in it for two years and had done
it was just like sofa TV like very
minimal
and I had to finish filming queer I come
home and queer I myself and actually had
my team do it and just like everywhere
but for filming like it needed to be and
then afterwards I'm like get it all out
get it all out I was too much i I need
to come home to almost nothing well I do
want to talk about your team I want to
talk about your interior design business
what will save that for the maximum I
got a pithy answer here Ryan for Mary's
question minimalism exposes the beauty
beneath the banality and I think
sometimes what happens is we clutter a
space with all of these these things I
and and we fill it up I got to put
something on this wall I've got a you
put this rug here and this and that and
whatever and all of a sudden the real
beauty is gone the the there's something
elegant about simplicity right I think
so yeah and you look at Japan right
perfect example it's one of the most
beautiful places it has its simplicity
yeah totally yeah I we were just talking
about that before we started recording
just how Japan is yeah aesthetically
awesome but everything's functional like
that it's almost like they're minimalist
out of function it's crazy I got to put
the answer here it is a mind is a
terrible thing to clutter so yeah if
your mind feels cluttered than the rooms
probably a little too cluttered I think
the other thing that Mary needs to look
out for is don't let other people's
preferences dictate her actions like
that is I think something that people
fall into the trap of doing all the time
they always ask me what's your favorite
trend you know what's the best trend
right now what's a trend that you love
the trend that you hate I'm like none
I'm like why had no one should be
listening to
I'm sorry magazines but nobody should
listen to listening to a magazine to
tell them exactly other homes should
feel they should know how their home
should feel your home is like your
charger your phone charger if it doesn't
if it doesn't fully charge you when you
go home you're not gonna make it through
the day just like your phone long so
don't listen to trends it's about what
you like if you like that purple and
yellow and polkadot ugly-ass painting
you know cuz that's what makes you tick
but that's not what makes me good right
don't put it up because a magazine told
you it's right or because your neighbor
really likes it or your friend really
likes it yeah you're trendy is a nice
way to say soon to be out of date
yeah and I think when we think about it
that way there are things that are much
more times and we're we didn't actually
share a memo of how we should dress
today but like like you could have worn
that in the 60s you could have wear
right now and any time in between it
would have been perfectly appropriate
and and I think the same can be true for
a beautiful home if you want your home
to be beautiful it's like what is
appropriate now should have probably
been appropriate 20 years ago 30 years
ago and so I think about that Mary when
when you are you know you're looking at
your space and saying I want this to be
me what is you and then fill that space
with what you are because as Ryan
mentioned if you do have that cluttered
mind you have the cluttered space the
and the opposite is also true our
physical possessions are a physical
manifestation of what's going on inside
us so if you want to deal with that
internal clutter you have to make sure
you don't have a bunch of external
clutter as well all right before we get
into our added value segment and our
listener tips today it looks like we
have a bunch more surprise questions
this week yes we do right
why does walking through IKEA make me
want to hurt myself this way of all
those cuts on your arms I think Bob
you'll be able to help us out with that
what's the best way to incorporate
shelving without it looking cluttered is
it possible to have kids and still be a
minimalist in a smaller home what are
some timeless styles and elements we can
incorporate into our spaces so that we
aren't just chasing trends how do you
deal with housewarming gifts people give
you but that you don't want what should
I do with all the stationery and paper
work in my small apartments do what I do
you make bunch of stacks everywhere
paper stacks like home I'm sure that Bob
you have a better answer than that also
we're gonna talk about lighting in
spaces small spaces big spaces how
lighting can improve your space plus a
bunch more questions and if you want to
hear all that listen to this week's
maximal episode that's right you're
currently listening to our minimal
episode but each week Ryan and I and our
guests we record an entirely different
much longer much more personal maximal
episode on the minimalist private
podcast which is the best way for us to
fund this podcast and keep it a hundred
percent advertisement free
to the most private podcast on patreon
you'll also receive a personal link so
that our maximal episodes play in your
favorite podcast app find all the
details at the minimalists dot-com slash
support Ryan what else you got for us
this week here I got some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners
check them out
hi Josh Ryan and the minimalists team
this is John from England I just thought
I'd let your listeners know that the
philosopher Peter Singer has purchased
back the publishing rights to his book
the life you can save so he can give it
away for free you can download it as an
e-book or an audiobook from the life you
can save to org the book looks at how we
can do our part to end world poverty and
how we can maximize our charitable
giving in a way that benefits the world
hi there this is Meredith calling from
Melbourne Australia I just wanted to
call in because I lost my beloved
grandmother Norah two years ago and we
were so so close and when we were
organizing her home following her
passing there was a lot of stuff in
there that you know she had herself
hadn't really used for many years to be
honest and I was wanting to you know
carry on celebrating her life but just
didn't feel willing to take on all of
the stuff but the few items that I did
take with me and bring into my home or
our home that I share with my husband
were a couple of really practical items
so I kept Mama's Mixmaster Mama's soup
ladle and Mama's tea tea cozies so there
are three things I can just think of off
the top of my head actually very few
other items I did keep but those three
things are really practical things which
mean that when I'm using those things at
home and I use them in my my daily life
well I'm using them I'm talking to mama
I'm thinking about mama and these things
add value to my life in a really
practical way so rather than just being
on a mental or
being the funny old China you know girl
with a bunch of balloons that she had on
her mantelpiece these are things that
she would use in her own kitchen and I
can carry on using in my own kitchen and
to just keep the things that that you
can use and when you do use them that
you can start a bit of a conversation
with that loved one and you know talk to
them as if they were here because that
certainly adds a lot of value to my life
with Mama whenever I'm I'm thinking
about her and missing her alright y'all
thanks again to Bobbie Bourke for
joining us today check him out at Bobbie
Burke com you can also follow him on
Instagram he's just at Bobbie
you follow him over there and check out
all of his interior design tips and
tricks his web site is just a plethora
of information about how to basically
how to fix your home make it more
minimal make it more aesthetically
pleasing and make it more beautiful make
it more you and real quick for right
here right now here is one thing
actually two things going on in the life
of the minimalist site or in a tour if
you want to see a home tour since we're
talking about interior spaces right now
Ryan and I both have home tours on our
web sites used to go to the minimalists
comm /resources you can download our
free home tours video of each of our
homes and you can check out the the
aesthetics and in both places and also
speaking of tours Ryan and I are getting
ready to go on another tour we're coming
to a city near you
we're doing eight cities along the west
coast of the United States and Canada
but even if we're not coming to a city
close to you right now if you get on our
email list over it they're the
minimalists comm / tour you can be
notified as soon as we announced the
city closest to you and during this next
tour the West Coast tour in April we're
gonna do a live version of the
minimalist podcast we have a special
guest in every city a podcast guests
also a musical guest in every city you
can find all the details on our website
the minimalists comm slash tour you can
follow the minimalists on facebook
twitter and instagram at the minimus if
you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast email a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
com comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalist and if
you want our show notes in your inbox
for our email list over at the
minimalists comm you also receive our
simple Sunday emails each week for added
value this week there's this band called
Pine Grove are you familiar with them
Ryan all the cool kids are yeah so I
figured you wouldn't know their third
album just came out it's really good I
don't even know how to describe it it's
maybe it's it's rock music but it just a
tinge of pop it's 98 percent rock 2% pop
music and their new album is called
marigold this is an album called
out or this is a song from that album
called alcove so check out pine Grove's
alcove from their album marigold and if
you leave here today with just one
question wait one question one message
what's your question I guess the
question could be love people use thing
how could you love people and use things
more in your life because they no no
let's just let's just go with the Stan
on question because they obviously never
works and minimus
[Laughter]